Today we're learning English with
Disney Pixar's newest animation Luca!
This movie is set in the beautiful
Italian Riviera and tells the story
of the curious and enthusiastic Luca, who like
any other child is eager to explore the world.
If you haven't seen this movie don't worry
because the two scenes that we have selected
for today's lesson contain no spoilers!
If you want to keep learning with the best
movies and TV series, so that you can finally
watch them without getting lost, without missing
the jokes and without subtitles make sure you hit
that Subscribe button and the Bell down below.
So that you can experience
something similar to Ahmed,
who actually recommended our channel
to more than 50 of his friends
who all subscribed and are having a positive
change to their English language learning.
If you want to keep on improving your
listening with natural conversations
then you have to download the RealLife English
App. You can listen to our podcast and follow
along with the transcript as well as
have short conversations with other
English learners from all around the world!
It's what you need to become a fluent speaker.
The best part is is that it's available to you
right now at the touch of a button for FREE.
That's right, absolutely free!
All you have to do is visit
the Google Play or the Apple App Store and
search RealLife English to download it now.
You can also click up here or
down in the description box below.
I hope you've enjoyed learning with Luca
so far today. Don't forget to check out our
Disney playlist, which is designed for you to
keep on learning with your favorite animations.
You can also make sure you visit our
Instagram @reallife.english that you can
continue learning with us every single day!
So now you're going to watch again without
subtitles and participate
in a fun quiz. Good luck!